cinéma depuis cet après-midi sur nos
écrans le film de Jacques Doyon petit
frère c'est le regard porté sur des
enfants de banlieu parfois en difficulté
mais toujours plein d'imagination les
acteurs des enfants ont appris aussi à
improviser reportage à pentin sur le
tournage de petit frère avec Michel
montponet et Jean-Paul
Chausset k quand tu vivais tu était
vivant pour moi mais toi même si tu tu
es plus du tout vivantexiste même plus
la vie des petits frères c'est d'abord
un territoire celui de la cité plutôt
couleur
galère les films de Doyon c'est d'abord
aussi un terrctoire celui de l'enfance
mais plutôt couleur
tendresse mais le film petit frère est
bien plus qu'une histoire d'enfance dans
la cité c'est l'histoire d'une
écoute celle de Doyon bien sûr pour des
gamins dont la vie hésite encore à se
dessiner fermement entre débrouill et DL
les dérapages vécus comme une
fatalité et tout cela donne un film
bouleversant
d'authenticité tu peux retrouver ton
chien comment ça je peux le retrouver il
des grand qui revent pas cher vers SOS
le chien 1000 francs ouais 100 Kos où
sont ces bâtards que j'allis shoter
douchement c'est des lions c'est pas des
petits [__] comme toi retraitement
d'enculé [__] de ta
race ça va se finir vite je con à faire
ta petite [__] [__] tu m'as déchiré
tu peux avir les soches ou pas non je'y
sais pas j'attendais le meilleur deux
donc savez que j'attavais le meilleur
deux assez vite ils sont acceptés de de
faire de très gros efforts pour que il
soit qu'il y ait plus de charme ou qui a
même un petit peu de magie de temps en
temps sur C ou de grâce tout simplement
tuessaes de faire mettre un mouchoir sur
ta honte et on essaie de faire avec
beaucoup moins de honte parce que la
honte m'intéresse pas ces préadolescents
dont l'innocence s' Filoche chaque jour
un peu plus sont le cœur battant de ce
film
admirable admirable d'attention mais
aussi de regard comme il faut regard je
pense qu'il a raison et ce soir après